joining us now to analyze the coverage
Molly Hemingway's senior editor at the
Federalist and a Fox News contributor
Griff Jenkins a Fox News correspondent
here in Washington and in New York
Jessica tarlof of bustled also a Fox
News contributor Molly New York Times
headline yesterday a White House in
denial do you believe the media are
mainly trying to portray this pandemic
as a monumental Trump failure well
they've been clearly trying to do that
for many months now in general the media
are not very good at explaining context
or nuance we learned this week that the
CDC estimates that ten times as many
people have coronavirus as have tested
positive that's what it means when you
test more people you're gonna find more
cases the CDC thinks that it's already
more than twenty million Americans who
have it what we need to know are not how
many cases there are we need to know how
like the hospitalizations are how many
people are even being hospitalized how
many people in which age group have this
and one of the things about the recent
increase in cases that they're by and
large predominantly in younger age
groups which are much better suited to
handle it in in this entire story we
have seen that it's not just older
people but older people in nursing homes
who are most at risk you know between a
third and a half of all deaths related
to this have been in nursing home so we
need to have much more focus on people
who are vulnerable there and much less
about people who are asymptomatic at
younger ages getting this Jessica the
good news is that the death rates are
way down but still more than 125
Americans have died of this disease do
you see the President as downplaying the
pandemic even with these latest numbers
reflecting the surge and blaming the
media for exaggerating the impact yeah
he absolutely is he did that in his
rally in Tulsa and I would argue that
Mike Pence when he finally got back on
television with the Koba task force did
the same thing essentially giving the
president a victory lap I see nothing to
be celebrating right here even if it's
people in my age demographic now who are
getting it versus senior citizens who
are obviously at more risk of having to
be hospitalized and unfortunately on
eventually die from this disease I think
the president's hold back and forth on I
was kidding I wasn't kidding he really
hung his press second
Terry Kelly Mackin any out to dry when
she made a statement in the briefing
room that says you know the president
was joking and then he comes out there
and says oh I never kid why are you
joking about people's lives and of
course the media is going to cover this
when we are getting crazy stats out of
Texas Florida Arizona places that had
reopened are and are having to scale
that back Grif would you agree that the
media for several weeks especially
during the protests pretty much pulled
back from this story and kind of send a
signal that it's kind of over as a huge
national emergency I would agree that
they put the front and center the the
violence in the streets the civil unrest
it was capturing our attention and of
course we've had no shortage of guests
talking about the apocrypha with local
leaders who did not move to stop the
social distancing that was being
violated in those situations but you
know you raised a point you know we saw
vice president pants now canceling his
trip to Florida in Arizona because of
the coronavirus concerns and really
what's most important about this
discussion I think is that the virus is
the only a political player in all of
this and the data matters significantly
I interviewed yesterday a real smart
expert avec Roy who says look if you get
hospitalized in Florida you are 85 years
old you have a sixty-one percent chance
of dying but if you're 25 it's only a 2%
chance these facts matter and that's
what's missing I think from this
conversation right but of course the 25
year olds can give it to older people as
well I think it was a huge media
miscalculation I said on this program
two weeks ago that I think the press had
grown tired of the story was repetitive
and it's kind of depressing Molly what
do you think about Jessica's point about
testing because yes President Trump and
others have said all of these numbers
scary as they are reflect increased
testing some public health experts say
it's beyond the increased testing it's
more positive rates when you do test
well it's important that we change as
new facts come on the ground when this
began it was extremely scary and we were
seeing certain results in testing rates
and now we have a much lower case
fatality rate we have a
much greater survival rate we have
learned so much more about how it
affects people in different age groups
and that's where I'm not seeing the
media coverage change they're still
acting like we don't know anything about
this or that we need to have the same
level of fear we had before there is a
certain amount of risk with this there
is a certain amount of reasonable fear
but when you're always making it 5 10 20
times as scary as it actually is that's
not helpful we need to have better risk
comparisons I mean there's risk with
everything we do in life the risk for
people below a certain age group is very
very small the risk for people in
nursing homes is very high one in six
just just under 1 1 in 6 people in New
Jersey in nursing homes died that's a
scandal and I don't see enough coverage
of that in our media they're trying to
make it sound general when it's a very
focused problem and one that we're not
paying enough attention to there and
we're acting like it's the same level of
risk for people who are in school or
what not when they actually are not
spreaders of the same in any way the
same Jessie let me get you to respond to
that but also this data point which is
the Washington Post reports that
President Trump's own mentions of Kovan
19 declined by two-thirds from April to
early June and I think the media take a
lot of cues from POTUS yes absolutely I
mean he dominates on that chosen social
media platform for politics right and so
everyone is going to have to follow his
lead there but we know why the president
doesn't want to talk about it he is a
reelection campaign to run and he wants
to be the law and order candidate he
doesn't want to be the sorry 125,000
plus Americans died and I was out to
lunch January in February when I should
have been preparing for this I think a
lot about the op-ed that Joe Biden wrote
on January 28 saying that President
Trump is the worst person to be in
charge if we're gonna have a health
pandemic and look at that Biden was
right and look at that binds up about 10
points right now the number one issue in
elections the last two cycles has been
health care it will be the number one
issue again so the president can go to
his border wall all that he wants he can
talk about how black lives matter as a
terrorist organization etc but when
people are dying whether they're 85 or
whether it's 30 35 year olds that are
getting sick and don't know the
long-term implications we've heard that
this could have
long-term capacity implications for
younger folks people are going to be
thinking about health care first and
foremost it's also an economic issue as
we know with people who are underinsured
but again the media's coverage I believe
has been spotty at times now
Griffith just so happens as was
mentioned earlier that Mike Pence
chaired the first coronavirus taskforce
hearing in two months it wasn't at the
white houses at HHS president of United
States did not appear Princip n said
we've made remarkable progress
dr. Fauci who reports they've been kind
of sideline from TV and dr. Burks urged
caution did the president all of this
essentially canceling the daily show of
the coronavirus task force kind of
dampen the media's interest possibly and
to that point it's a good one you raised
Howie because maybe they should bring it
back on a daily basis because again as
Jessica points out I think accurately
where this virus is and how the
country's handled it 130 so days from
now is going to depend who wins the
White House and it appeared even though
the president at one point wanted to do
away entirely with the briefing there
was a hunger in a consistent hunger of
the American people for information for
the data for the recommendations and
really now in the absence of those
briefings we're getting you know
national debates over whether you should
wear a mask or not I think you would do
himself a favor by bringing it back full
force
all right we're a little tight on time
Molly let me pick up on groups point why
is this whole debate about whether
people should wear a mask when they go
out in public or in crowded places why
is it become so politicized is it in
part because the President Trump is not
publicly embraced wearing a mask himself
and hasn't fully embraced the
recommendation lots of governor's
mayor's vice presidents are certainly
warmer at times why do you think that
the coverage of this has become so
politicized well we might begin at the
beginning where we were told that masks
did nothing to prevent the spread of
coronavirus we had these experts you
know even in the Trump administration or
at who saying that they weren't
necessary then they say they are I think
that again it's an issue of nuance
people are unable to understand but
there might be times where you're
wearing a mask in times where you aren't
and on both extreme
you have people just saying either you
know that you have to wear it at all
times or you don't
in general we just need much more
accurate coverage of actual risks being
outside exercising for instance being
more than six feet apart you don't need
to wear masks right and just quickly the
same question about the the shutdowns
and whether they were too quickly and
should they come back it seems to become
a big partisan issue for the media yeah
absolutely but there were big mistakes
that people my own party made there have
been articles in left-leaning
publications that said that if Cuomo for
instance had shut down New York a week
earlier and taking the example of what
they did
London breathed it in San Francisco that
we could have saved a lot of people's
lives and certainly not had the
nursing-home scandal at the level that
we have that's New York in New Jersey
where it's been the worst and those are
blue states but to Molly's point about
the president he has to lead by example
the Surgeon General says wear a mask the
president should wear a mask all right
meanwhile you know you may be watching
this in a state where the corona virus
is not surging but in Florida in Texas
they shut down the bars it is a better
situation in New York and DC where most
of the media are base which is why think
maybe a little bit of slowness to
recognize where we are today